hey this is pressure Locker here's a
slightly edited version of an email I
got high I got this problem in an exam
in Hungary for 15 year-olds at first I
could not figure it out I got so
frustrated that I was thinking about it
all day when I finally got the answer I
was so happy now the problem when empty
a container fills completely from a
faucet in eight hours when full the same
container drains completely if it's
drain is open for be hours if the faucet
is on and the drain is open at the same
time how many hours will it take to
completely fill the container you are
given that the absolute value of a minus
B equals one by Daniel from Hungary can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution
so I appreciate that Daniel didn't just
send me an email asking me for help to
figure out the problem which I'm getting
more and more of every day
I appreciate that he actually spent the
time to work on it all day and try and
figure out a solution so how can we work
through this problem so I actually
missed one of the cases and Daniel
pointed out that my answer was
incomplete the first case you should
consider is if a is greater than or
equal to B this means it takes longer
for the faucet to fill the container
than for the drain
to completely empty the container in
that case the drain empties as fast or
faster than the faucet so the container
will never get full the other case is if
a is less than B in that case after T
hours the faucet would fill t over a
percent of the container and the drain
would empty t over B percent of the
container so the percentage filled in
the container is the combination of
these two fractions we have t over a
full minus T over B that gets drained
now we want to solve for when the
container is completely full to 100%
100% is equal to one so we solve this
equation to be equal to one we do this
by multiplying both sides of the
equation by a B we then end up with TB
minus T a equals a B we give them factor
out the T and then divide by B minus a
to get T is equal to a B divided by the
quantity B minus a now we also know that
the absolute difference of a and B is 1
and in this case a is less than B so
this means B minus a is equal to 1 or B
is equal to a plus 1 therefore the time
will be equal to a
e / 1 so it equals a B which can also be
written in a number of other ways using
the relationship that B is equal to a
plus 1 or a is equal to B minus 1 we can
write it as a times a plus 1 which
equals a squared plus a we can write it
as the quantity B minus 1 times B which
we can write as B squared minus B or we
can just leave it as a times B so that's
the answer did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions if you like this video you can
check out my books which are linked in
the video description you can also
support me on patreon if you have a
puzzle suggestion or a math topic you
can email me presh at mind your
decisions comm you can also catch me on
social media either at mind your
decisions or a pressure tell Walker